konaté mort
qui est conrad
michel carter 17 ans elle passe trois
jours a envoyé des textos en disant que
son copain a disparu qu'il est peut être
mort mais le truc c'est que c'est faux
elle était en contact avec lui tout du
long jusqu'au moment où il a coupé tout
contact avec tout le monde elle lui
disait de le faire elles l'encouragent m
j'arrête pas de découvrir des choses sur
lui c'est comme si je ne connaissais pas
c'est extrêmement touchant de voir tous
réunis pour conrad comment imagine la
mort tout je crois que c'est comme
flotter sur alors
et ils ont ouvert une enquête sur ton
lien avec la mort de conrad rails mais
pourquoi j'ai rien fait de mal ils ont
échangé beaucoup de messages des miniers
on pourrait être un peu comme roméo et
juliette j'adorerais être d'âge il y est
mais tu sais comment ça finit c'était sa
première tentative de suicide ce gosse a
des antécédents dépressifs pourquoi
cette fille serait responsable cette
fois-ci aider quelqu'un à se suicider
n'est pas illégal elle lui a dit
froidement de boire de l'autre a valu il
n'arrêtait pas de dire qu'il voulait
mourir je voulais simplement l'aider si
ça se termine en gros c'est ça fera
jurisprudence
lind ont fait vous connaissez le caire
fait rater votre piste je suis coincé
ici moi ce que je peux faire pourquoi
est ce qu'elle voudrait qu'il se donne
la mort
cette histoire les quarts
je veux raconter notre histoire
notre histoire d'amour